The Framy application encourages creativity
By making it possible to create animations and characters
Using a wide range of real facial expressions.
Clicking just a few buttons
Framy can create movie-like effects
Combine images with videos.
But Framy is not just a tool for producing videos
But also a basic system
You can express yourself and your feelings.
The app provides a great channel for sharing your custom animations
Share stories inspired by your imagination
With people all over the world.
Google has a great deal of expertise and tools
To help you create a successful app development business.
He also introduced the Google Play app for Framy
Lots of useful ideas and tips.
For example, the Google Play app recommends a multidimensional design
With Framy enabled from creation
New design chart
The interface is simple and unified.
And during the framy establishment
Developers also use it
Various services provided by Google
Such as Google's staged offering feature
Framy is an application that includes many innovative new features.
And through Google's staged offering feature
The Framy application can offer new features
To a limited group of users
Based on their comments and reports
We review the issues and make improvements to these features
Before being put to the public.
The subtraction feature contributes significantly to the stages
Design new experimental features for the Framy application.
Framy also used the Google Cloud Test Lab.
This feature allows you to test the Framy application on multiple devices
Saving a lot in terms of the number of trial users and the time taken.
We can then make system adjustments according to device types
Thus greatly improving the user satisfaction
Towards the performance of our application.
Among Google's various features
Framy also uses Google Translate
Which allowed the use of different languages
Language barriers were minimized
Through the Framy application page on social networks.
This has led to tremendous improvement
In app user ratings
Which increased from 3.5 to 4.1
The figure continues to improve.
In the future, Framy will continue to implement the development process
And the process of merging related Google services with its user interface
To make a Framy application
A unique application that is suitable for users and everyone enjoys using it.